no doubt at all that if putin makes this
choice russia will pay a heavy price
speaking from prepared notes on the
anniversary of his first year in office
president joe biden sought to clarify
the u.s position on a russian invasion
into ukraine
i've been absolutely clear with
president putin he has no
misunderstanding if any
any assembled russian units move across
the ukrainian border that is an invasion
but it will be met with severe and
coordinated economic response
it comes as the white house spent the
day cleaning up his wednesday night
remarks stunning european allies by
suggesting a lesser response to a
smaller scale invasion
if it invades and it depends on what it
does it's one thing if it's a minor
incursion and then we end up having a
fight about what to do and not do
etcetera
trains president vladimir zelinski fired
back on twitter blasting biden's
comments we want to remind the great
powers that there are no minor
incursions and small nations zelinski
tweeted just as there are no minor
casualties and little grief from the
loss of loved ones i say this as the
president of a great power
biden's statements of a potential
russian invasion of ukraine have exposed
the divisions and doubt about the united
states commitment among european allies
there is concern among allies that the
u.s if we don't have did not have the
will to follow through on our own uh
us-led activity in afghanistan how much
are they sure that we will follow
through in protecting allies and how
much are we willing to protect
non-allies when european european
security is in the balance
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
is in geneva for a meeting with russian
foreign minister sergey lavrov russia is
seeking to halt a nato expansion and
membership for ukraine and moldova the
u.s will not provide such assurances but
instead will encourage diplomacy to
resolve security differences
there is new urgency to the negotiations
president biden warned with russian
troops positioned close to ukraine's
border he believes russian president
vladimir putin intends to attack
and a russian invasion of ukraine may be
imminent
kimberly helkin al jazeera the white
house